simply claiming something is a
conspiracy theory doesn't necessarily
make it false not anymore and the more
that comes out about Epstein including
still very mysterious circumstances
surrounding his death in custody means
that I'm willing to at least consider
alternative narratives other than the
one being fed to us through official
channels now joining me now is the
author and investigative journalist
Vicky Ward the author of of war against
the Jews and Jeffrey Epstein's former
lawyer Alan dtz and the man I mentioned
in my monologue physicist and podcaster
Eric Weinstein thank you all so much for
being with me uh tonight first of all
Vicky Ward if I may you wrote uh
commissioned to write an incredibly
important article way back in
2003 about Jeffrey Epstein it was called
The Talented Mr Epstein and you've since
said that that there were significant
efforts to sort of keep some of your
Revelations out what exactly happened
there well you know what happened there
was Jeffrey Epstein um you know he was
an extraordinary manipulator not just of
uh young vulnerable women but of Rich
powerful men and you know uh what
happened in my reporting was that uh you
know I still don't know all of the
details but I had uh the on the record
allegations of uh two sisters two women
um and you know those those allegations
were cut from uh my story and you know
Jeffrey Epstein had gone to Great
Lengths to meet with then edit editor of
uh Vanity Fair um and at the same time
you know Jeffrey Jeffrey epon was a
formidable person uh to write about you
know he he threatened me I was pregnant
with my children and he told me that if
he didn't like what I wrote he would uh
have a witch doctor place a curse on my
unborn children he told me he'd found
out where I was giving birth uh you know
I I I add this didn't stop me from
reporting the absolute uh best that I
could and I did debunk some of the
claims he made about his own Financial
professional life um but you know the
whole thing was Douglas a
nightmare can I ask you also Vicki just
quickly um were there any of the names
that released today which surprised
you no I didn't know about um David
Copperfield and I don't think I'd read
um about Stephen Hawking but no they
didn't they didn't surprise me I mean
you know I've been covering this story
for over two decades so I was very
familiar
with a lot of this I mean what it just
did was solidify a picture by putting
specific names in places but I think
that unfortunately the documents still
don't show a different part of Jeffrey
Epstein's life which is the manipulation
of the powerful people it was it was a
horrific portrait of uh this horrific
sexual subculture in his homes but it
didn't explain why people like Bill
Clinton
um and massive philanthropists like
Leslie Wexner why they wanted to be
around this man and I'm sure your other
guests are going to have a lot of
insight into that because it it wasn't
because he had a whole group of of
underage women around him um thank you
Vic can I just come next to Alan dtz um
thank you so much Professor dtz for
being with us um first of all of course
you were Epstein's lawyer at one point
and you were also named in these uh
released docum ments today how do you
respond to
this well first of all the woman who
accused me has now admitted that she may
have confused me with someone else may
have been a case of mistaken identity
and she's dropped all of her legal
charges I first met Jeffrey FC and I was
introduced to him by the lady Rothchild
um and uh um she asked me to meet him
because he was a major contributor to
Harvard and I agreed to meet with him
and I went to some seminars that he
conducted at Harvard president of
Harvard with uh major major academic uh
uh figures but from the day I met
Jeffrey Epsy until the day he died I
have had sexual contact with one woman
and one woman only my wife and so I was
one of those who wanted these papers to
be released my disappointment is that
only some have been released I want
everything to be released because they
will confirm the fact that I did nothing
wrong and they would also shed light on
other people who have been uh accused
some truthfully some uh falsely some
falsely but um the key point is that uh
we can't have just partial uh releases
of material in many of these cases the
accusation is there but the rebuttal is
not there or the disproof is not there
so for the public to form a valid
judgment uh you need a full release I
don't need that because in my case the
woman who accused me has admitted that
she may have mistaken me for someone
else but I think others may very well
need the full evidence to be exculpated
and to Pro some don't want it because
they may very well on that very just
very quickly I me President Clinton is
mentioned more than 50 times in these
documents and he maintains he never
visited Epstein's Island uh Donald
Trump's also mentioned in there but uh
should do you think politicians and
others should explain their exact links
with Jeffrey
Epstein yeah for examp I'll give you a
story I was having dinner this is a name
dropping story with Caroline Kennedy
former president's daughter and her
husband and Bill Clinton and another
couple and the phone rang this was on
Martha's Vineyard and the secret he was
President the Secret Service gave him
the phone he went away walked for about
15 minutes had a vibrant conversation I
didn't hear it and then he came back
with the phone and saying Allan somebody
wants to say hello to you and he handed
me the phone it was Jeffrey eping so
this was way before any accusations or
anything was suggested about EPC but
obviously Clinton and EPC had a
friendship and in most cases in my
example my friendship totally terminated
the day the accusations came out I did
serve as his lawyer but never again
socialized with him once I had heard
these accusations I think that's
probably true of some people in other
cases people contined to have a
friendship with him even after he served
his sentence in prison and they do have
some explaining to do but that doesn't
prove guilty just let let me bring in
Eric Weinstein has been patiently
waiting in La Eric we uh we heard
earlier a bit of uh your description of
Jeffrey Epstein you met him once more
than 20 years ago can you just quickly
briefly recap you what your impression
was uh simply that um he uh was
introduced to me um in a financial
context I was uh interested in
investment in a so-called uh carry trade
in foreign exchange he didn't seem to
have any interest in that uh he said
that he was a uh currency Trader uh
there was no obvious evidence that he
was a currency Trader he didn't speak
like one um and he seemed to be very
interested as per the uh previous
comment about stepen Hawking um in my
work on what might be called post
einsteinian physics in particular if you
check out his sponsorship of a
conference that he held in the Virgin
Islands called confronting
gravity um he was very interested Ed
in um science this obviously is an area
with potential military applications
it's uh he was a very strange person
from beginning to end I don't really
believe this when you say that that he
was a strange person I me describe some
of the things that were odd in that
first meeting that meet that one meeting
you had sure uh I don't hear anyone
mention the fact that he used an
American flag as a tablecloth making his
dinner table looked like both a coffin
and a trap for you to stain the flag of
your own country uh he brought in a
woman who um I think he introduced as an
ays uh who was braless that he bounced
on his uh leg at a financial meeting uh
in an attempt to create a
distraction uh the whole thing was
completely surreal from beginning to end
I think one thing that you can learn
about this is that he created an
incredibly uh intriguing World there was
no hint I think this was like 20 2003
2004 so this before he gets into trouble
in
Florida um and you know the whole thing
was like a scene out of a movie and you
both wanted to be nowhere close and to
know everything about it and I walked
out of there called my wife and said uh
I just met a human being who does not
appear to be a normal human being he
appears to be a construct somebody
appears to have constructed something
that looks like a finance year but if
you scratch the surface doesn't behave
like one doesn't seem to know a lot
about science although he's very
interested in science nothing made any
sense up was down left was right black
was white well we're going to have to
take a short break but I want to keep
all three of you here because I want to
get back after the break into this
really crucial question of who Jeffrey
Epstein actually might have been who do
we think he was we'll be talking about
that and much more after the
break welcome back to uncensored still
with me today our author and
investigative journalist Vicki Ward
author of the war against the Jews and
Jeffrey Epstein's former defense lawyer
Alan dtz and the physicist Eric
Weinstein let me just very quickly Eric
I just wanted to ask you quickly uh what
you were saying before the break what is
the actual allegation you're making who
do you think Jeffrey Epstein actually
was I don't know it's a great question
um but I knew that he wasn't who he said
he was almost from the instant I started
speaking to him um if I had to make a
guess and you're calling for speculation
I would say that he really belonged to
uh what is almost certainly the covert
operations community and um that he uh
did not appear to have a prime broker
nobody seemed to have traded with him
nobody uh seems to ask questions uh
around him so it's very suspicious that
we don't for example ask for form 13f if
he was a major hedge fund Trader
it's almost impossible to move through
the markets without leaving awake uh if
you have to speculate I would say that
he probably belonged to covert
operations uh for one or more um Nations
and that what we're looking at is a very
strange you can shake your head Allan
but it's also the case that I don't
necessarily believe that you stopped
associating with him personally uh at
the time of his um conviction in Florida
because uh I think there are pictures of
you at the um program for revolutionary
Dynamics uh socializing with Pinker
triers I don't know you tell me I'm
gonna have to go back to Alan dtz on
that Alan dtz how do you respond all
before that uh no he was not a member of
any intelligence agencies I'm I'm quite
sure of that um and uh he was not a
hedge fund guy in fact once this is a
you never want to tell humerous stories
about Jeffrey Epstein but he once said
to me he wanted to sue newspaper for
defamation I said why did they call you
a pedophile he said no they called me a
hedge fund guy uh he was very upset at
being called the hedge fund guy um I
don't know what his financial business
was but I can be relatively certain he
was not an asset for the can I just ask
why can I just ask why you're so certain
about this because it does seem to have
been an intelligence gathering operation
of some kind or
compromat.ru it's possible but I never
saw any evidence of that he was a guy
from Brooklyn grew up in Coney Island he
was very curious he wasn't a smart as he
thought he was he didn't know as much
about science as he thought he did but I
can tell you that people like Stephen
Pinker and people like Stephen Gould and
people like U the president of Harvard
thought he asked good questions during
the seminars that we all attended those
seminars I never attended a seminar
after um I represented him my
relationship did terminate I continued
to take his phone calls after that look
I don't know who Jeffrey Epstein is he
was very very I didn't even want to meet
him initially but uh lady rild assisted
and then some people at Harvard said
they wanted me to put together some
people to attend a seminars of his and I
did that and um and and we learned a lot
I met people at Harvard that I had never
known even been on the faculty for 50
years men and women VI let me just come
back to Vicky Ward quickly you've been
waiting patiently but um I mean a man
who apparently boasted to Associates
that he had compromising material film
footage and others of important
individuals and that's not the normal
way in which anyone behaves is
it right Douglas so I mean one thing we
did learn in the papers that came out
last night is that you know he did in
some of the depositions ask the women
who claimed that they were sent out to
men to give them very detailed
descriptions of what had happened so
that he could use it to Blackmail them
um I've never seen that spelled out
quite so specifically before and then to
your point about you know the question
who was Jeffrey Epstein here's what we
do know that is not speculative he did
know the Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia he
did know Muhammad bin zad the ruler of
the uh United Arab Emirates uh he did
know very well AUD Barack the former
prime minister uh of Israel that
pictures of all of these men he there's
a picture of him uh I think I believe
with the Pope there was a picture uh you
picture of him of all sorts of world
leaders and and we know that even after
he got out of jail in 2010 you know um
he he was clever enough to use the
connections he had with the academics
with the the former president of Harvard
with these other world leaders to draw
in other billionaires like Bill Gates he
understood how very rich powerful people
around the world connect with each other
he
understood what very rich powerful
people want from each other he
understood how to connect the plutocracy
and the elite does that mean he was an
asset I don't you know there is there a
speculation but it it is he he
certainly was a manipulator of the
0.001% um Eric Weinstein quickly just
coming back to you if I may quickly um
uh I think a name that quite a lot of
people have been rather surprised to see
on this list for perhaps several reasons
was Professor the late professor Steven
Hawking uh what on Earth we meant to
make of
this well I mean there's two separate
things one is that uh the state of
physics uh is bizarre in that um it's
one of the most consequential things you
could possibly study for military
purposes um and at the same time it has
been sort of more or less run into the
ground um so stepen Hawking was uh of
Interest probably for the same reason
that uh Jeffrey Epstein was much more
interested in talking to me about um
post Einstein and gravity than he was in
talking about car trades what professor
dwith says is very strange to me because
he advertised to me that he was a
currency Trader uh running a massive uh
hedge fund out of theart house in New
York on Madison Avenue and I dropped off
documents there so something is really
not jelling and one of the really
interesting things would be to have very
extensive discussions uh to try to
figure out who this person is because
the person who presented himself to me
was much more like the person who
presented himself to Vicki than the
person who presented himself to Alan dtz
now what I would say is that he had also
extensive contacts apparently with the
Harvard mathematics Department both
through Benedict gross and through uh
Martin Noak um Harvard is all through
the story and as we are learning Harvard
is a very strange Place uh I was there
for about 20 years uh it is sort of an
extension of the US government in an
unacknowledged
capacity and it has the only University
to really have the power to effectively
change The Narrative of academics in
particular very consequential Fields now
the other thing about Stephen Hawking
that you should just know is you should
probably do a search on the word San
Bernardino and Stephen Hawking uh it was
not uh a secret that uh Professor ha
Hawking had a very healthy appetite for
life and that this is not a new
revelation nor is the fact that he was
associated with Jeffrey Epstein uh a new
revelation so that there's something
very peculiar about the way in which we
are forgetting a tremendous amount I
would also recommend looking up the name
Craig Spence if the the suggestion that
this sounds like a completely insane
idea that he was connected to
intelligence uh Craig Spence is the
antecedent apparently of Jeffrey Epstein
it's just very strange that all these
things made the papers there's extensive
documentation on the internet we pretend
that we don't know let me just go Alan d
second he want to come back
in well of course he knew Stephen
Hawkings there are newspaper reports
about Stephen Hawkings having come to a
conference on his Island where he had
conferences so far not a single one of
the names that have come out has
surprised me I had heard all of it of
before but as the judge in the second
circuit cabanis once said if there's an
accusation made in court papers it's to
be less believed than an accusation made
to the media because if the accusation
is made to the media and it's false you
can sue for defamation whereas if the
accusation is made in court papers
there's a privilege and so the judge
said look skeptically at accusations
made in court papers look I want
everything out I want all the theories
out there all the documents let the
public decide there are people who don't
want things they have things to hide but
people like me who nothing to hide who
are not in any way embarrassed about any
of these Revelations because we know we
did nothing wrong we're the ones who
want all these papers out all these
documents out and I'm hoping the judge
will now release everything every single
document um I find that very interesting
because yeah yeah one of the things that
I find very intriguing is that Jeffrey
Epstein appeared to know all sorts of
things about me that were not public and
uh seem to require Quire almost a
periscope into my life in particular
scientific uh things about me that uh
probably flowed through the Harvard
Department that I was from which I took
my PhD I don't think that you're
grasping how strong the circumstantial
Cas is that this person was somehow uh
attached to intelligence and may have
benefited from things like U state
secret privilege and other forms of
Exotica and the law let me finish with
just asking a very quick but
pretty important question of each of you
one by one if you may just very quickly
of course the other thing that makes the
whole thing bizarre is the manner of his
death did Jeffrey Epstein kill himself
Vicki I think that whatever happened uh
he had help it didn't happen just by
himself Alan
dtz I have the same view I think he
probably killed himself probably paid
off guards to close the TV and other
things but but I don't exclude the
possibility that there may have been uh
third third parties involved I I'm not
sure that's why I want to complete
everything coming out enough speculation
enough inference let's get to the facts
and Eric
Weinstein if I had to speculate I would
say that I've never met a person less
likely to terminate his own life from
embarrassment than Jeffrey Epstein I
would put him first on the list of a
person who would be undaunted by being
worldwide known as a sex evant
thank you very M thank you very much
Vicky ward in New York Alan duritz in
Delaware and Eric Weinstein in La it's a
great pleasure to have you all on thank
you